all right guys
bang bang what's up lunch money time
well while she's trying to get richer
muscles just trying to get her lunch
money right i'm here with pelina ivalova
marinova pomp
liano p-i-m-p you can just say pp
that's weird okay don't forget that
lunch money is now sponsored by block
five block buy has three products you
can buy and sell crypto on a crypto
exchange you can deposit crypto and get
a us dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
or you can deposit crypto and earn up to
8.6
apy in an interest-bearing account and
today today
today they announced the waitlist for
the bitcoin rewards credit card
it's a credit card you spend credit but
rather than get cash back like in a
normal credit card
you get bitcoin back game changer
go into your block by account and
there's a wait list thing you can sign
up right there
go do it today don't get stuck in the
back of the line go to your block by
account and sign up for the wait list
what's up that's kind of cool also um
my hair is all crazy today i just woke
up guys but i put myself together real
quick okay
airbnb plans to price at 44 to 50
dollars per share in its ipo giving it a
valuation of up to
35 billion on a fully diluted basis
the company seeks to raise about 2.5
billion in the ipo an existing investor
seeks to sell
96 million worth of stock in ipo i i
think
all this is reasonable yeah look at its
peers
i i actually think that this may be one
of the most
uh conservative ipos in a while
if i was brian chesky i'd be like a
hundred billion
let's go i would like that given that i
have a little little investment a little
tiny
little tiny investment are you one of
the investors seeking to sell
no i don't think i'm gonna sell i'm
gonna ride or die
so yes airbnb is gonna you tell me in
five years airbnb is not gonna be bigger
than it is today
yeah it will so airbnb like be like as
the pandemic began
it cut 25 of its staff for 900 employees
but it quickly saw its business rebound
as people were like
we need to go to the woods and we need
airbnbs because we don't want to stay in
hotels or
we want to go with a friend or whatever
so
i mean nobody knew what was going to
happen back in may but look at that well
remember it cut 25
of its staff too yeah i just said that
and then there's like 1900 employees oh
rewind all right go somebody's not
listening
okay what you're not listening i missed
that part
okay next online sales
reached 10.8 billion dollars on cyber
monday which is the biggest
u.s e-commerce day ever
how do they know this already they know
it monday's
it ended nine hours ago how did they how
did they count up all the e-commerce
across all the different platforms
it's called the technology no no
no because this is this is an analytics
it's according to adobe you're going to
tell me you don't trust adobe
no what i'm going to say is that there's
no way everyone is reporting all of the
numbers to
adobe analytics what i'm so what i'm
saying is i think it's higher than this
number
okay so the largest day ever true but
i'm just saying you're telling me that
the one was this article published this
morning at 9 30.
okay so in nine and a half hours they
counted all of the sales that everyone
in the united states did yesterday
just with technology there's sites that
track this stuff
the own companies don't even know yes
they do no they do not
by the way shopify claimed that did 5.1
billion dollars yesterday can i just say
can i just say
what not one positive thing to come out
of this horrible pandemic
is the cancellation of black friday
shopping we don't need people going and
and
what is it called trampling trampling is
that is it a word
trampoline you trampled over somebody
trampling over each other
at stores over a freaking tv
well not for our tv but a ps5 i might be
up in there trampling over somebody
so fun story our first when we first
moved to the us
like we moved in like april and then
thanksgiving wasn't thanksgiving in
november
and so people told us you got to go to
the stores the day before
and wake up at 5am because everything
was going to be on sale and we were like
whoa
and we went and i think we went to
walmart and it was
the worst day of my life i was like
never again
never setting foot in here my mom was
like what the hell is this country
it was absurd and absurd welcome to
america you were like nine or ten
i know and i remember it clearly yeah
get ready for consumerism
no problem we built our country on
consumerism
it was out there all right speaking of
consumerism softbank
on the heels of facebook taking a big
step into customer service with the
acquisition of customer for one billion
dollars another big move is a foot in
the world of
crm cinch a swedish company that
provides cloud-based
omni-channel voice video and messaging
services i have no idea what that means
to help enterprises communicate with its
customers has announced that softbank is
taking a 690 million dollar stake in the
company
wow softbank's giving somebody 690
million dollars they basically use audio
video and voice to literally talk to
their customers
shocking i know absolutely not why don't
they just give it to
and what they're gonna do with the 690
million dollars they're gonna go buy a
bunch of other companies
that that's what this article said well
i didn't need to use the word afoot to
describe it
that is a pretty good word i may start
using that word oh my god
bitcoin was a foot of 20. so one time he
was on the phone and he goes
um it would behoove you and i turned
around and i was like
how do you know what behoove you means
because i'm smart and i read the
internet and i
understand the english language but
sometimes she uses the wrong word for
the wrong situation so that's always
funny
everybody knows what i'm trying all
right um egg
specially come on okay
um all right so international restaurant
franchise pizza hut
not to be confused with domino's pizza
has begun accepting cryptocurrency as a
form of payment in venezuela
listen pizza hut got some ass pizza it's
disgusting
like i never had a pizza hut pizza and
been like man that was a good meal
never never and i eat dominoes
so it is ass like straight up little
kids stop trying to go to pizza hut it
sucks parents stop taking your kids up
pizza hut it
sucks but i like the fact that they're
accepting crypto now
so i might be a pizza hut business fan
but a pizza hut pizza bear like
you guys gotta fix the pizza man what do
you think i've had pizza hut and so
don't it's like eating cardboard like
literally they just
wheeled out the boxes and then they
forgot to put the pizza in it and they
just tell you to eat the cardboard it's
absurd are you ready for this one i love
this yeah
ass pizza where are you guys that's like
sweet pizza hut's uh
uh tagline pizza hut where you can eat
ass pizza
are you done yeah go ahead jesus sorry
but hey shout out for accepting crypto
in venezuela
a 12 year old boy in atlanta has dreams
of going to mars
those dreams are not far-fetched look at
the boy as the boy has already been
accepted into college
caleb anderson is 12 years old and he is
currently enrolled in high school and
takes classes at a local technical
college
in the fall of 2021 he expects to enroll
at georgia tech
hey man why are you trying to be so
educated look at look at what he said he
goes
uh try to get my masters of georgia tech
then do an internship with elon musk and
then i'll probably get my phd at mit
and then i think i'll start working in
either nasa or spacex
he's got his path to mars lined up hey
you know what i was doing when i was 12
trying not to go to school what is this
kid doing
i like that he's smart i like that he
already knows
i like that his dad was like he's kind
of always been this way where he'll ask
these deep
profound questions and you don't expect
to see that from a three-year-old
that's gonna be our approach can you
imagine if you had a little
three-year-old and he was asking you
like
so how do you calculate like like i
don't know man go google it i
did that i asked a lot you were asking
calculus questions
and laughs and chemistry questions last
night guys i try to figure out health
insurance and anthony tried to explain
it to me in a million different ways and
i just didn't get it and i got
flashbacks to like doing my math
homework in high school
so i started crying i was like i don't
get it i do literally
literally she started crying like who
makes this
up why she was like what do you mean
there's a
a monthly premium and then there's a
deductible and there's a max payment
yeah he's doing math and it was it was
bad no because
i am paying more and then on top of that
i still have to pay
they make money off people like you
that's who they make money off no they
yes they don't it's up to me i'd be like
screw this i'm never going to the doctor
yeah they make money off people like you
you're they're like oh if you pay the
least amount per month
then they get you on the back end yeah i
wanted the catastrophic plan the one
that's like i am dying
take me to the hospital but at that
point i'm willing to pay anything
why would i pay every month in case
i don't i don't get it somebody i don't
know how insurance works
all right next next next next is lunch
money time
all right what questions how was pomp oh
sorry valexis asks
how was pomp introduced to bitcoin 2014
i was working at facebook and somebody
started talking about it this guy
david marcus who uh we had hired from uh
paypal
and uh he was talking about for
remittances and all this uh
crazy stuff uh i asked an engineer that
worked with me i said hey
like what what is this stuff is this
real he was like it's stupid
okay never googled it never did anything
uh dumb and then in 2016
uh a kid jp barrick uh who i know when
he was in high school he was now like a
freshman or sophomore in college
uh he came and saw him and he was just
like dude you got to pay attention to
this and he told me about uh mining
and so the first thing i ever did was i
bought a bunch of mining rigs
and got them set up and was like oh this
is cool and then kind of went down the
rabbit hole from there the lesson in
this story guys
always talk to young people facts
okay nasami
asks so after doing our bitcoin dance
and laughing at the bears how do we make
sure we keep our crypto
ultra safe i mean i've got a ledger but
what if
what if bitcoin goes to 500k and i'm
sitting here with my ledger
would we need a vault or a third party
who keeps us secure or just a very good
theft insurance
i don't know anything there's theft
insurance okay
also puzzles are awesome what's up
nissani
we're keeping you away from any
insurance you're done you can get
insurance you're done with insurance uh
short answer is
obviously that uh one if you have
custody of your own keys
that is the most secure because you have
the custody of the keys
uh two is you can definitely get uh some
insurance there's different providers
that are out there
uh and then third is um there are
exchanges or uh who provide cold custody
so it's a custody service provided by
the exchange coinbase has one i think
gemiini has one etcetera
uh and then on top of that there are
actually custody providers so whether
it's anchorage or bitco
or whoever that you can actually go and
give them the crypto and they'll hold it
for you
and that's their business fidelity does
this also
and so i think that the key is just like
what works for you um you know holding
the private keys most
like bitcoin especially like the
hardcore bitcoiners they would say
that's the best thing to do
there's some people who that scares the
hell out of and they just they don't
feel comfortable doing it they feel like
they don't understand it they're scared
there's a lot of money on the line all
that kind of stuff
and so they'd rather use one of these
third-party services whatever you want
to do there's an option for you it's
kind of the way that i think about it
my biggest thing is just don't be
clicking on random links
use two-factor authentication don't use
two-factor authentication on your text
messages
and also make sure you got a plan wait
explain that don't use two-factor things
so a lot of times when you go to sign up
for our website it's like hey we just
texted you a code
right that's two-factor authentication
the first authentication which you typed
in your password
they send you a code then you type in
the code that's your second factor of
authentication
the problem with using it a text based
two-factor authentication
is somebody can basically take over your
cell phone number uh it's called sim
swapping they literally convince the
cell phone company that they're you they
send you a sim card they use it
now when you get the text message they
get the text message so they go to your
thing they figure out your username or
whatever they hit like password recovery
says hey we just texted you a code you
get the code and they get the code
on their phone because they put a sim
your sim card in their phone
uh and then they can quickly take over
your account so what you want to make
sure you're using
is two-factor authentication using
something like google's
uh two-factor authentication app or
authy
i think there's a couple of others that
are out but isn't the app like if they
have control over your phone you can
no they can't because it's based on the
hardware
so it's not a text message interesting
cool learn something every day
well thank you guys that's all i have to
do is that it yeah all right
everyone have a great day see you
tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block 5 so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account go do your own
research
there's risks associated but 8.6 is
pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends